Si j'étais 1 pays européen pour sa politique écologique,
je serais
je dirais la France parce que c'est le 1ère pays, euh.
Avoir mis en place en Europe 1 ministre de l'écologie.
Si j'étais 1 capitale européenne, je serais,
euh, je serais Paris.
C'est là qu'on a mis en place la cup,
euh. Vingt-et-un, qui était la cup, euh. Phare.
Si j'étais 1 pays
européen pour sa politique d'immigration,
je serais peut-être l'Espagne
parce qu'ils arrivent à trouver 1 bon
mix entre euh.
Fermeté quand-même et intégration.
Si j'étais 1 personnage historique européen, je serai,
je serai le général de Gaulle,
parce qu'il a 1 vision de long terme,
notamment sur le nucléaire.
Si j'étais 1 pays européen pour son régime politique,
je serai la Suisse.
Si j'étais 1 monument européen,
je serai peut-être le Colisée.
Si j'étais 1 marque de voiture européenne, je serai,
bah, j'irai Renault.
Si j'étais 1 chanteur ou 1 groupe de musique européen,
je serais, moi, j'aime beaucoup Vianney.
Si j'étais 1 pays européen pour sa météo,
je serais peut-être le Portugal.
Il fait toujours très beau au Portugal.
Si j'étais 1 drapeau européen, en terme d'esthétique,
je serais
j'irais le drapeau italien parce qu'il y a du vert.
Si je n'étais pas français, je serais, euh.
C'est impossible, non, que je serais français,
français et français